bonjour chanter un synthé donc d'appeler
nabila je fais un petit résumé de votre
carrière donc vous aimez bien le
shampoing ouais j'aime trop voilà pascal
praud a déclaré à l'issue de la
rencontre psg marseille
la pelouse était humide et vous
alors si votre copain était un dessert
ce serait plutôt un mystère une
religieuse ou un gland quoi un gland
cesser le gâteau vert avec des trucs
qu'on longe comme ça quoi un gland ne
connaissez pas mais non ce n'est pas un
gâteau qui s'appelle un hub à ce jeu
vous en offrir avec plaisir à nancy ça
c'est super bon c'est comme une
religieuse au chocolat d'être très
anglaise de d'empêcher serait singles ça
des trucs qui tombent des arbres donc
sans le gâteau je parle je ne fais pas
un gâteau aucun dégât toi comment il ya
un autre va chercher chercher sur
internet ainsi à penser comme en bas
vous me voulez pas aussi la page vous
parlais justement quelle question que je
pose souvent et à tout le monde en
période électorale
euh vous embêter les autres parce que
j'étais
j'étais en train de regarder mes tweets
alors c'est quoi le dernier par exemple
on est on est curieux vous me suivez pas
sur twitter voulait que vous suivre sur
twitter même je vous suivent sur twitter
vous avez twitter vous déjà je vous
promets vous avez pas vous avez pas la
tête à voir plus tard je vais peut-être
avoir quoi je sais pas lire l'extrait
slam ou vous avez un fax depuis 15 jours
parce qu'avant je renvoyais tout par la
poste ou tanger un fax la paix qui c'est
qui fait ça genre je crois que quand
j'en ai pas beaucoup donc ils seront
donc peut-être qu'ils ont d'autres trucs
de tisons ça et moi je leur lis moi je
vous envoie un fax mais faut se mettre
aux mails vous voyez ah ouais c'est
important puisqu'il faut que vous me
parlez des trucs préhistorique
c'est une période électorale que pensez
vous des candidats sans étiquette
candidat sans étiquette
ça veut dire quoi elle sans étiquette ou
pas non pas une étiquette
ouf mais ce qu'on perd du coin à partir
de quel moment un livre n'est pas un
livre
bah ça c'est un peu compliqué pour moi
sur un magazine est un magazine peut
être un livre ou pas ah non un livre il
ya un glas les grands livres
gallen page là on est les petits livres
les magasins la dépense de la taille est
un magazine avec plein de pages on peut
considérer que c'est un livre bah ouais
voilà kouteiba jeu c'est tout ouais je
vous remercie